DANA HAN-KLEIN: Today it
is my absolute pleasure
to welcome the
Editor-in-Chief of io9,
and the award-winning
writer, Charlie Jane Anders,
for "All the Birds in the Sky."
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Thanks
so much for coming out.
"Laurence first met his
girlfriend, Serafina,
at a robot fashion show, with
robots modeling human clothing
and humans modeling
robot fashions,
like mechanical lingerie.
The event happened at a garagey
artspace somewhere south
of South of Market,
with a gunmetal trough
full of artisanal vodka.
Laurence had come this close
to mistaking Serafina for one
of the models-- her
cheekbones and oval face,
her lustrous skin and
shiny red/black hair
were that amazing-- but
he realized just in time
that she was one of the
robot makers instead.
Serafina's model
was a steel sylph,
with ball-and-socket
joints that let
it strike a pose, pivot,
talk with its delicate hands.
Laurence had helped to build
battle bots in college,
but never artificial
supermodels,
and he had managed to say
something witty enough
about the difference
between the two,
that Serafina had
friended him on MeeYu.
They met for coffee a
few days after that,
and the coffee date
morphed into a dinner date.
And the third time
they hung out,
it was tacitly a sleepover.
Serafina had a
toothbrush and condoms
in a pouch of her
vinyl shoulder bag,
which was Twiki
from "Buck Rogers."
Protip-- do not think
of "beedi beedi beedi"
while you're having sex for
the first time with the most
beautiful woman alive.
Or you will have some
explaining to do,
even if your motion,
rocking the bed frame,
does have a sort of "beedi
beedi beedi" rhythm to it.
After that, they hung
out every other day,
held hands in the streets,
skipped through traffic,
whispered in each other's ears
in public, clung together skin
to skin in every
moment in private,
and swapped gene prints,
traded odd little gifts,
and wondered how soon was
too soon to say I love you.
Laurence had soon
found out that letting
people know that he was
part of the 10% Project
was a super-fast
ticket to getting laid.
Laurence was
finally a rock star.
About time, really.
And yet, there was
still no way that he
was in Serafina's league.
She was perfect.
He was damaged goods.
He never forgot this
disparity for a second.
About a month after
they started dating,
Serafina took Laurence
into her sanctum.
She had to sign him in.
And he had to surrender
his ID to the man
at the desk, who printed a badge
with Laurence's fresh photo
on it.
She led him down an elevator
along a sloping hallway,
through two keypad-secured
doors and on into the lab.
Inside, eyes watched
Laurence from every wall
and flat surface.
Four of them belonged to bearded
humans who said, yo, and then
looked back down at
their workstations.
But the rest all
belonged to robots
in various states of assembly.
Serafina barely introduced
Laurence to the two humans,
but took her time showing
him the robots, who
were animatronic cartoon
characters or animals,
or a few mannequin heads.
'This is Frank.
He laughs a lot.
Watch out for Barbara.
She flirts, but she's got a mean
streak.' The robots all seem
to like Laurence, especially
Donald the Cactus.
By now, Laurence
and Serafina had
been dating for five months.
And lately, every time
Serafina looked at her phone
while they were hanging
out or stared into space,
or bit her thick lower lip in
the middle of a conversation,
Laurence braced himself.
This was it.
She was going to dump him.
Then the moment would pass.
Laurence was sure
that she was just
waiting for the right
moment or the ideal pretext.
Every time he woke
up next to her,
he wondered if this was the
last time her breath would warm
the back of his
neck and her breasts
would graze either
side of his spine.
He was not going to lose her.
He had aced bigger
challenges than this.
He was going to
think of something,
take extreme measures, even
deploy the nuclear option early
if he had to.
He was going to find a way to
hold on to this amazing girl.
Serafina was late for dinner
because her emotional robots
had been having a nervous
breakdown-- all of them.
'It took me the whole
day to figure out
what was bothering them.
They just kept wigging
out and giving us
all the hairy eyeball.
We looked at everything
that had changed in the lab,
trying to eliminate
any possible variable.
Like, was the music different?
Did we update their
code recently?'
Laurence didn't rush her.
Problem solving
and troubleshooting
were a source of pleasure
for both of them.
And narrating the process
was the next best thing
to doing it.
The same neural pathways lit
up when you talked your way
through the maze as
when you actually
solved it for the first time.
Except this time you were bathed
in the glow of already having
unraveled the thing.
And yet, Laurence was
still uncomfortable.
For one thing, because
Serafina was late,
they were stuck sitting at
one of the sidewalk tables
at the fancy pizza place
with nothing but a tiny heat
lamp and three meatballs to
insulate them from the fog
until the pizza arrived.
For another, he was trying
to be a good listener because
of his ongoing
not-getting-dumped project,
and active listening
was hard work.
We finally figured out the
one thing that had changed.
Serafina said, she
wore a camisole,
but she'd put her bulky
jacket back on when
they were seated outdoors.
The heat lamp made
her skin look bronze.
Matt just got a Caddy, and he
brought it into the office.
Soon as we took the
Caddy out of Wi-Fi range,
the robots calmed
down-- somewhat.
And before you ask,
the Caddy did not
have any weird apps
installed on it.
It was fresh from the store.
Wi-Fi range, so they
were getting something
from the Caddy on their wireless
network that upset them.
Laurence pulled
out his own Caddy
and glanced over it,
as if he would suddenly
spot some brand-new feature.
It still looked like
a big guitar pick
with a curved base,
covered with aluminum.
The Caddy was scanning for open
networks, the same as always.
But it wouldn't link
up with other machines
on the same network without
being instructed to do so.
Unless-- 'Here's
what I don't get,"
Laurence said, bisecting
the third meatball
so Serafina could have half.
The meatball was
their only protection
against the cold, the last
of their dwindling supplies
until the pizza arrived.
'So, your emotional
robots, I mean,
they don't have emotions in
the way that humans do, right?
I mean, no offense.' Laurence
was on thin ice here.
And not only the edge,
but the dead middle
of a lake, 100 fragile
paces in any direction.
'I mean, the robots
simulate emotional responses
to some situations.
And then they try to pick up
on what the people around them
are feeling.
Right?' 'You make it
sound like we're designing
three-dimensional game avatars.'
Serafina didn't quite
push her chair back,
but she did seem a
little further away.
'I'm aware it's a lot more
involved than that,' Laurence
said, 'both because
of the uncanny valley,
and because the physical world
is a lot more complicated.
But the real point is, how
do you know your emotions are
spontaneous and genuine and
not just a preprogrammed set
of responses?'
'I don't.
I wonder about that all the
time.' Laurence was conscious
that it was probably a bad idea
to confess to your girlfriend
that you often wondered
if your feelings were just
an involuntary response.
'I just wonder--
I mean, assuming
that they have a particular
feeling, a reason for feeling
a particular way, and
they don't just wake up
on the wrong side of the bed?
I mean, the Caddy had to be
doing something that resembled
an aggressive act as defined
in their response matrices,
right?' 'Yeah,' Serafina said,
'they reacted as if they were
being threatened.'
The pizza came at last, just
when Laurence needed something
to distract Serafina from what a
mansplaining dick he was being,
in spite of all his resolutions.
'I mean, there has to be some
other explanation.' Laurence
said, 'you're talking
about a Caddy.
It's not a black box.
People have jailbroken, and--'
Sorry, I just lost my stopwatch.
OK.
'people have jailbroken
and wiped them.
They've installed Linux on them.
And they've also
ported the Caddy OS
over to cheap imitation
tablets from Liberia.
This is the most hacked
device in history.
If there was something
weird about it,
we'd know by now.' 'Hey,'
said Serafina, chewing pizza,
'Ockham's razor is not just
an optional weapon in Street
Warrior V. I already told
you, we eliminated all other
possibilities.'
The harder Laurence
tried not to screw up,
the worse he screwed up.
He was not going to get dumped.
That was not a
possible outcome."
So I'm going to skip
a little bit ahead.
There's more about the Caddy,
this miraculous device.
So Patricia, who was the other
main character in the book,
is a witch.
And she's been going
through a crisis.
And we pick up there. "Patricia
was fixing Reginald's sink,
which had one of those
glitchy new valves
that were supposed
to shut off the water
after a couple of minutes.
And she found herself talking
about her latest breakup.
And you know, her fear that
she was just always going to be
alone. 'I mean, I just never
have time for anybody,' she
said, 'I just keep
isolating myself.
I'm just basically doomed to
wind up alone forever, right?'
Patricia expected Reginald to
offer some bromides about how
she just needed to be herself.
But instead he said, 'Get--
a-- Caddy.' 'What?' She nearly
bonked her head on the sink.
'Get.
A. Caddy.
It will change your life.
I am not kidding at all.
You become totally connected
to all the people in your life.
Not like regular social
networking either.
It's uncanny.
You will just run into people
you know, in person, when
you most need to see them.
I could barely afford
one on my fixed income.
But it turned out to be
the best investment I ever
made.' 'I always thought
Caddies were just for mission
hipsters."
Patricia said, "Anyway,
it sounds creepy.'
'Seriously, no.
It's not creepy.
And it's so easy to use.
It doesn't spy on you or tell
you to stalk your friends.
I never felt like it
was invading my privacy.
It just makes serendipity
happen more often.
It's unobtrusive, and it doesn't
give you a bunch of alerts.
But you'll always
know what's the one
party that you shouldn't miss.
I was feeling
isolated, even with
your much-appreciated visits.
And then I got this Caddy,
and I feel as though I'm back
in my own life again.'
In spite of
Reginald's insistence
that the Caddy was not all
creepy, his hard sell in itself
was kind of creepy.
He sounded like someone
who had just joined a cult.
Patricia vowed that she would
never, ever buy a Caddy.
Ever.
Two days later, Patricia
was in the Caddy store,
near Union Square.
It was narrow,
with curving walls
that drew you towards
the counter at the back
like a stream curving
around some rocks.
The walls seemed to glow.
Patricia picked up a Caddy
from the display on one wall,
and the screen flared to life.
There was a swirl of colors.
And then it resolved
into a wheel shape.
The wheels had swirls
coming out of its center,
sort of like a Taoist symbol.
And each of them got
bigger when she touched it.
They included things like
communication, orientation,
self expression,
and introspection.
She paid for the Caddy
with her ATM card
and felt like a total wanker.
Next, she was just
going to go get
some giant square dark
glasses and a medallion that
changed color depending on how
recently she had gotten laid.
God!
Still, it was a fun toy.
And at this point,
she would try anything
to make herself feel less
claustrophobic and isolated and
self-absorbed.
Although there was something
perverse about buying
a device that offered a
huge introspection wedge,
in the hopes that it would
make her more social.
That night, Patricia sat in bed
and played with her new Caddy.
It was not that different
from the standard tablet,
except for the
guitar-pick shape,
and the way that it insisted on
asking you demented questions
to customize your experience.
Like, would you rather lose
your sense of smell or taste?
When was the last time you
were glad you stayed up late?
There was a check box to
disable the questions.
But everybody said they made
it work a million times better,
and they tapered off
after about a day.
And sure enough,
after a few days,
the Caddy was steering
her oh-so-gently
towards happy accidents
and little discoveries.
There was that little
egg-themed restaurant
in Hayes Valley, where
everybody sat in egg chairs
and ate egg dishes,
from Scotch eggs
to Chinese-style egg tarts, and
drank cocktails with egg yolks
in them.
The whole place was an
allergy waiting to happen.
But it was also warm and cozy.
And there was a faint smell of
butter and sugar in the air,
making her feel like she was in
her grandma's kitchen and five
years old.
The Caddy helped
Patricia figure out
which bus to take to
avoid being late for work.
And when one of her Mary
Janes broke a strap,
the Caddy steered her to this
hole-in-the-wall place that
fixed it on the spot.
Within a few days, Patricia
had a low-level awareness
of what a dozen or
so people in her life
were up to at any given moment,
without feeling overwhelmed.
She managed to grab lunch
with her friend, Taylor,
and make time for an
ice cream conference
with her roommates,
Deedee and Racheline.
Then something weird happened.
Right around the
time that Patricia
had gotten used to the Caddy,
and started thinking of it
as an extension
of her personality
rather than just an appliance--
after about five days,
in other words-- she started
running into Laurence.
A lot.
At lunch, at dinner, at tea,
on the bus, in the park.
At first it didn't
seem like a big deal.
Because San Francisco
was a tiny town.
But after a couple of
days, it felt weird.
She would see Laurence, say
hi, mumble a few awkward words,
and then bail.
And then the process would
repeat a couple hours later.
She would think that
he was stalking her,
except that she was the least
stalkable person on the planet.
The third day, she tried
shaking up her routine,
going for a vegan soul
food in the outer sunset.
And somehow, Laurence
was there too,
going to some kind of
musee mecanique revival.
'Uh, hey again,' he said.
He started to say
something else,
and then seemed to
think better of it.
She was already saying, 'Hey.'
and turning back to talk
to Taylor.
On her break at work,
she picked up her Caddy
and scrawled, what's
the deal with Laurence?
With her finger.
The Caddy responded by telling
her some facts about Laurence,
including some physics
prize that he'd won at MIT.
She couldn't help feeling
like the Caddy understood
the question perfectly
and was just playing dumb.
She decided to leave
her Caddy at home.
And for a whole day, her
life was boring again.
Just missing the bus and not
connecting with her friends,
and not having
time to grab dinner
in the middle of doing errands.
The rain started just as she
was heading home for the night.
And she had forgotten
her umbrella.
And there was no
place to buy one.
And of course, she
had to run 10 blocks
to catch the bus, which
left just as she got there.
She waited another half an hour
under a disintegrating canopy
for the next bus.
And when she staggered on
board, drenched as a sponge,
the only seat-- the
only empty seat--
was next to Laurence.'
I'm going to stop there.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So I
think it's hilarious
that-- I would love for
all of our UX designers
to read about Caddies.
And I'm sure they would all
love to make one magically
work as well as it does in
the universe you've created.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: I want one.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah, so thanks
so much for joining us today.
I think the first
question is what
inspired you to write the book?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: You know,
it started out as just sort of,
like, thinking about putting
these two genres together,
fantasy and science fiction,
in kind of one bundle.
And then when I started
to really think about it,
I started to think of it more
as the story of these two
people, the mad
scientist and the witch,
and less like just you
know, kind of a genre story.
I got more excited about
their different world
views and their different
kind of feelings
about magic and science
and nature and technology.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: What were some
of the challenges of weaving
together a universe that
combines those without flaw?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: I mean,
basically, the main thing was
there was a million challenges.
But in terms of bringing
together the science fiction
thing and the fantasy thing
of these two characters,
you know, the worldbuilding
was a challenge.
Like, making the fantasy
world feel grounded and real,
and like, something
that could actually
co-exist with a realistic
"world" of machines
and computers and stuff.
You know, it meant that I
couldn't really go crazy, like,
full-on Harry Potter
or just have, like,
magical shit exploding
all over the place.
It had to kind of be a little
bit more grounded, I guess,
and like, something
that actually you
could believe was in our world
and that was all around us
without people noticing.
And then with the
science stuff, again, I
couldn't go to broad with the
kind of Jimmy Neutron-- Boy
Genius side of it or whatever.
Because I wanted it to
contrast with the magic as much
as possible.
So the more, kind of, it
felt like they're working
for startups, they go to MIT.
They have a loft in Soma or
whatever, that kind of stuff,
the more it felt
like real-life geeks.
The more I believed
in it, and the more it
was a good counterpoint
to the magic stuff, which
was more of a made-up world.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Speaking
of real-life geeks,
since we're at Google--
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Yeah.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: --what sort
of research did you do,
in terms of-- I mean, there's
probably more research
to be done in terms of the
scientific side of the book
than the magical
side of the book.
But that might just be my bias.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Yeah,
the magic side, I just
had to do a lot of thinking.
And I'd read a lot of fantasy.
And I had to just make sure that
I had something that actually
had internal logic
and wasn't derivative
of other stuff I'd read.
With the science stuff, I talked
to a jillion science people
about the physics in the book.
And actually, there
was somebody who,
I think she's a post-doc now.
Or she was working at
Microsoft for a while.
She was getting her PhD
in computer science.
She's done a lot of stuff on AI.
And she spent hours
going through, like,
the AI stuff in the book.
And part of the book, as
you can see, from the stuff
about the Caddy,
there's kind of a theme
of AI emerging from our personal
technology in our gadgets
and the things that we
interface with every day,
and that we depend on
to enable our lives now.
And that's not
something, obviously,
that I came up with that's
been in a million other things.
And the movie "Her" came out
while I was writing this book.
And I was, like, damn!
Because I feel like "Her" beat
me to the punch a little bit
on some of that stuff.
But there's been a
million other things.
That's almost a
cliche at this point.
But I really wanted
something that
was a realistic AI in
a consumer gadget kind.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I
mean, it's something
that we, at Google,
and other companies,
are trying to work on.
You know?
Google Now.
And it's trying to
make your life easier.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Yeah.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So if you had
to pick, if you could only
live in one world,
a world with magic
or a world as a super
scientist, which would you pick?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: I mean,
I guess if I could be, like,
one of the witches in
Patricia's world, that
would be pretty awesome.
Because they can do some
pretty amazing stuff.
But you know, there's
a huge cost to it.
So I don't know.
It's tough.
I think, yeah, the magic world.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So the book
is set in San Francisco, which
we're near.
And it was great for me,
because I'm from the Bay Area.
And reading, you know-- San
Francisco could be fiction
if you haven't been here.
So what did you
weave in, in terms
of having to weave, pretty
much, a made-up place
into a made-up place?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
I mean, a lot
of the stuff in San Francisco
is the real San Francisco.
Like the part I just read
there, at Pizzeria Delfina,
and later in that section, they
go to the Latin American club
on Humphrey Slocombe, It's,
like, right-- you know?
There's real places.
I think the egg
restaurant in Hayes Valley
doesn't actually exist.
There's a couple places
that are a little bit
like that in Hayes Valley.
There's that
bookstore-bar place that
has a little bit of
an egg thing going on.
But I guess it's
not really the same.
But you know, then I
just tried to kind of,
like-- there are things, like,
where the magicians live.
Like, there's this used
bookstore that one of them
lives in, which is right in
the middle of the Mission.
And I just kind of drew
on some real places
and kind of changed it
around a little bit.
So I mean, there was so
much other made-up stuff
in the book that was kind
of just completely out
of left field, that
as much as possible,
I wanted the setting to
be just 100% grounded.
And there was a little bit
of like-- because that stuff
all takes place
10 years from now.
And it was like, do I
really think, you know,
Pizzeria Delfina will
be here in 10 years?
Do I think Humphrey Slocombe?
I don't know.
I hope so.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: They already
got the breakfast cereal.
Did you always know you wanted
it set in San Francisco?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Yeah.
I mean, the first
third of the book
isn't set in San Francisco.
And then I think
I decided to set
the grown-up parts
in San Francisco out
of total sheer laziness.
Because I just didn't
want to have to deal with,
like, if I set it
in some other city,
that it'd be a
lot more research,
and making sure that things
actually felt-- you know?
Even like New York, or Boston,
where I've spent a lot of time,
it's just not
quite as automatic.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
One thing you did
that I thought is
really interesting
is that you've actually shared
parts of the book that didn't
make it into the book online.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Oh, yeah.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I'm actually
curious as to the motivation
behind this.
Is it just sort of,
like, DVD extras?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Yeah.
I mean, it is kind
of DVD extras.
I have a Tumblr,
allthebirdsinthesky.tumblr.com,
where I've been just posting
deleted scenes from the book.
And it's mostly just because
there's so much of it.
The book was, like, a
billion pages longer.
And there was a lot
of stuff that I really
liked that I had to
cut just for length.
And some of it adds to your
appreciation, or hopefully,
your understanding
or whatever, of some
of the supporting characters
and some of the other stuff
that's going on.
And I don't know, I think
it's fun to see that stuff.
And it's probably going to
never be used anywhere else.
So might as well post it.
And hopefully people like
it and it doesn't just
give a weird impression
of what the book is
like, since it's
all the stuff that
actually wasn't in the book.
I don't know.
Fingers crossed.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: No, it's cool.
It's just one of those things
where I was like, well,
you could have written an
entire other book based
on the additional materials.
I'm wondering, obviously,
when you're working for io9
you consume and analyze a lot
of science fiction and fantasy
in media.
And did you ever
find yourself going,
oh, I'm going to
hold back because I
know this person did this?
Or was it sort of
encouraging to be,
like, well, I know this
person did this well.
So I'm going to do it better.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Yeah, I'm
definitely super-hyper aware
of what's been done.
I mean, not all the time.
I'm sure there's like things
that I'm not aware of.
Because I can't know
every single thing.
But I kind of know the
things that people are
people have been excited about.
And that's kind of weird,
being that hyper aware.
But I feel like
that's all of us.
Like, we all kind of are
hyper aware at this point.
Like, I was in a writing group
years and years and years ago.
And someone wrote a
short story or a novel
where there was an AI named
Michael or named Mike,
or whatever.
And everybody was, like, oh
my god, how could you do that?
What are you doing?
Because that's the name
of the AI in "The Moon
is a Harsh Mistress,"
by Robert A. Heinlein.
And it was, like, why
would you name you AI Mike?
Is this some kind
of weird shout out?
Or are you just, like,
you know-- I don't know.
Anyways, so things like that.
You can never entirely
avoid stuff like that
unless you just have, like,
encyclopedic knowledge
of the genre, which I
definitely do not have.
So that's another
reason why you have
to show it to people
and also just trust
that your editor, at some
point, will pin you if you've
made a mistake like that.
But yeah, it's tough.
The more time goes on,
the more stuff there is,
and the more you're likely
to be ripping someone
off without realizing it.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So
paying them a compliment.
Imitation is the sincerest
form of flattery.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
It's an homage.
Yeah, exactly.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So who are
some of your inspirations?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: For
this book in particular,
the number one inspiration
that I always talk about
is Doris Lessing.
Because she is an
incredible writer,
who did this kind of weird blend
of science fiction and realism
in a lot of her books.
Especially this
five-book series,
the "Martha Quest" series, which
I encourage everybody to read.
Because it's amazing.
It starts out super, very
tightly autobiographical,
about a young woman
growing up in Africa
and getting involved in
Marxist politics in the '50s.
And she wrote it over a
period of, like, 20 years.
And by the end, there's
like, nuclear war
and mutants and psychic powers.
And just like, it gets way
more and more out there
as it goes along.
But it feels kind of seamless.
It just kind of, like, it
feels like, OK, the world
was more normal, and
now it's not, kind of.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So the first
half the book takes place
and they're sort of
children and young adults.
And were there any books
that sort of shaped you
as a young adult, into
the writer you are today?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
I mean, I read
a ton of Judy Blume,
and like, Beverly Cleary
when I was a kid.
I love them.
I love "The Chronicles
of Prydain."
I don't know if that's
YA or middle grade.
But I loved those a lot.
And anything by
Daniel Pinkwater.
Daniel Pinkwater is,
like, the greatest.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: All right.
Do you have a favorite hero
or heroine in literature?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Oh man.
There's so many.
I don't know.
Yeah, I mean, I love
Katniss Everdeen, actually.
I think she's a great hero.
I think she's actually, like,
a really terrific character who
there's just so much
going on with her.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: And then if
you were hosting a dinner party
and you could invite three
authors, dead or alive, who
would you?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: God, I mean
definitely Vonnegut, for sure.
Vonnegut and
Lessing, actually, it
would be pretty hilarious
to see those two together.
I don't know.
And then I don't know
who the third would be.
Maybe Michael Chabon.
I don't know, that'd
be kind of fun.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: He's a nice guy.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Yeah,
one living author, at least.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
Is there something that you
wish you could tell yourself
when you set out to write
this book, that you know now?
Now that it's done
and published?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
I don't know.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I you
could do time travel?
That's part of it.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
Yeah, I don't know.
It just would have been nice to
know that it wasn't just going
to be a total flaming disaster.
I mean, at least not a
total flaming disaster.
I don't know.
For, like, at least a few
years, I was pretty convinced
that it was just going to
be a trash fire forever.
But I don't know.
I mean, the main thing
that was the mistake I made
was trying to go too
broad and over the top
with the humor at first.
And there was a slow process of
kind of peeling back the humor
until I got to something that
was a little more personal
and you know, kind of had
more space for the characters
and their emotions.
So that's something that
could've saved a lot of time
if I hadn't gone that way.
But I think that was
part of how I figured
out the world and stuff, is
just by making it really silly
and then dialing it back.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: When
you're building a world,
do you sort of set out the odds
of like, Sanderson has his law.
He says, OK, they can't do this.
And they do this.
Because there are some
trade offs and constraints
within the world you've
built. Is that something
you discovered along the way?
Or is that something
at the outset
you went, I know this
has to be a part of it?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
You mean with the magic?
Or just in general?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: With the
magic, but also in general.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
Yeah, with the magic,
I was definitely pulling
it out of my butt.
as I went along.
And then I kind of had to
figure it out a little bit more
when I was revising.
I mean, the main thing with
the magic, with the magic,
you kind of see it
two different ways.
Because you see
it for the first,
like, 100-something pages,
like Patricia is a little kid.
And she's just figuring
it out on her own.
And she doesn't know
any other magic people.
And so it's, like-- you know?
Excuse me.
It's just this mysterious
thing that she's
kind of struggling with.
And it's sort of
dreamlike and weird
and kind of crazy and trippy.
And then, the other
2/3 of the book, she's
integrated with magical society.
And they do have all their own
rules and their own history,
and their own
system of what magic
is, where there's
two different systems
that they've tried to
merge into one system.
And it's just I think that
stuff is a partial understanding
of magic.
And I feel like
part of what I hope
to get by the end of the
book is that nobody really
understands it.
You can come up with a system
and rules and all this stuff.
But that doesn't mean that you
actually understood all of it.
You've just kind of figured
out some stuff kind of.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: We
have an audience mic,
if anyone wants to line
up and take a question?
I think one of
the things for me,
actually-- it's funny that
you picked the first passage
to read from-- because
there was a moment
about the emotional robots.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Oh yeah.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I thought
that was so great,
the way you describe emotions.
It was like a virus state.
It was great.
I was, like, oh that's
something, weirdly enough,
like, I connect with this, as
somebody who works in tech,
or something like that.
Is that something that
you kind of stumbled upon?
Or is it--
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
The emotional robots?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
Is that something you've been
mulling over for a while?
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: I
just have known people
who worked on emotional robots.
And I've been around
them a couple times.
I don't know.
I mean, I guess
part of what it is,
is that I wanted her to
be somebody who works
with technology, who's
like, as bad ass as Laurence
is, as smart as him.
You know?
And I guess there's sort
of a theme in the book.
Like, part of the
thing with the Caddy,
too, is like, about
how we interact
with other people
and our connections
to other humans and stuff.
And so the idea of
emotional robots
was just another way of
getting at the thing of, like,
technology and
human interaction,
and how technology can
simulate that, but also
how technology
can kind of either
complicate or simplify
human interaction.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Sometimes inhibit it.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
Yeah, sometimes.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: We're staring
at our phones all the times.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
I know, sometimes that's true.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: But
there'll come a day
where robots know us better
than we know ourselves.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
I think yeah, that's
definitely going to happen.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Well, thank
you so much for joining us.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS:
Yeah, it was a pleasure.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: The book is out.
And we'll have a
signing after this.
Thanks, everyone.
CHARLIE JANE ANDERS: Yay!
Thanks!
Woo!
[APPLAUSE]